okay I'm just gonna get started here
people are gonna be wandering in that's
totally okay but this is bringing
JavaScript's the IOT edge let's get
started first of all I just want to kind
of whet your palate a little bit I get
y'all excited about the topic so why
does this matter
why are we learning about IOT why are
you here you've probably seen this graph
before but IOT is growing and will
continue to grow I do want to put a
little asterisk here I think that IOT
has probably been a little hyped and I
don't think it's gonna be it's like
we're not seeing the growth quite that
way but I think that IOT is still
massive and I think it's still we're
still in the Wild West days trying to
figure out what what the hell it is
we're early this is early we're early on
on it too and javascript is a massive
part of the IOT ecosystem so the more
you know great so my name is Joe Carlson
I work for MongoDB and I'm a developer
advocate
those are my socials best way to get a
hold of me is actually on Twitter so
feel free to go there otherwise all my
social stuff is on my website opinions
are my own if I say something or swear
something it's not my company it's me
and lastly I'm gonna be posting this
link a lot but all the resources I post
in here including the slides all the
other links additional resources links
sort of this recorded session went to
the code link to videos all be on that
page so feel free to check that out I'm
just gonna wait here for a second so
people can take photos that people were
taking coder is that's too small to take
QR photos of that it got it cool awesome
even the back of the room got it that's
that's good though I'll be posting this
more yeah okay a little bit more about
me too
let's see how well I see people still
taking photos too
cool I will be posting this link or at
least this QR code again to so a a
little bit more about me
I love IOT and most of my projects that
I do on my own our Hardware related in
some some way this is a magic mirror I
put together it's a smart mirror you can
see does whether my currently playing at
Spotify some positive affirmations and
york times headlines calendar updates
weather whatever it's actually i didn't
make it it's part of a magic mirror
mirror squared project you can find more
about that down there you choose it
electron I did make this recently it's
called mood light those are 3d printed
panels and LEDs in the corner and I have
a little web app or a little web server
built into the little triangles anyone
your heard of Nana Leafs before they're
big they're super expensive you've
probably seen if you ever googled it
I decided don't want to pay $300 for
nine of them so I just made my own but
you can control the lights from that web
server running from those panels and you
can learn more about that down there
okay so before we get started and get
into the nuts and bolts of this I want
to first just thank you y'all for coming
I sincerely appreciate it I don't know I
have a cool job where I get to make cool
[ __ ] and travel around and talk to
people and it's because of you guys come
in these talks so I just really
appreciate it you know I think thank you
for being here and who's this talk force
this is gonna be for people who are new
to JavaScript or know to have some
JavaScript experience maybe be new to
IOT this is more of a kind of 101
introductory stuff we're not going to be
getting into nitty gritty about security
we have 30 minutes so we gotta kind of
book it through here but most
importantly even if you're like IOT
expert great like or none of the above
you don't do JavaScript you're still be
fine this talk is still for you I'm
hoping you'll still get something new
out of it too but great I want to get a
quick poll and just get a quick pulse on
where y'all are at so who here has IOT
experience like done a little bit maybe
mess around the Raspberry Pi before cool
cocoa cool like quarter half fish
and then JavaScript experience assume
everyone the room great okay cool cool
and again here's that linked where all
the resources can be found too so I
think everyone's want to get it yeah
I'll hold this up one more time I just
added these just to take your coat
that's so smart
I saw someone at a talk yesterday with
some of that your coat so links and like
that is so genius I quickly added a
bunch into my talks but okay so road map
what do we mean what's the stock in old
bike today I'm gonna do a quick
introduction IOT what it is what I love
about it we're talking about JavaScript
and node and IOT and why you should be
considering using them for your next
project I'm going to talk about some
data practices I'm in MongoDB developer
advocates so it's kind of I'm gonna be
okay I think I have to talk about data a
little bit with it so which is cool
actually and I didn't know a lot about
this too so I hope you learned about
there too and then I want to talk about
a real project so I've been working on
an IO to smart kitty litter box in my
free time I've actually been stringing
on twitch so we going over that project
in particular and then lastly we talking
about my predictions for where IOT
something going in the future right so
what the heck is IOT it's basically
anything that has that connects up to
Internet and by thing I mean anything
it's the future we're seeing lot stuff
like right smartwatches fitbit's I think
the part that people don't consider with
with IOT is like automation especially
with like fact manufacturing smart
plants connected devices but I think we
see the consumer products quite often
and think about those being IOT projects
my personal personally I'm interested in
two parts about IOT
I love the stupid [ __ ] have you ever
seen a Twitter account Internet of [ __ ]
where people make like like toaster
ovens that connect to the oven or or
like toilets like I'm putting together
here I think we don't know exactly what
it's capable of yet so we're just
putting chips and everything and kind of
figuring out what's
dick someone doesn't I can love that
actually I ran a hackathon in Hawaii
called the stupid [ __ ] and terrible
ideas hackathon was inspired by another
hackathon it got started in New York
City I love I love that fine line
between just a stupid idea and a kind of
a genius idea I think that's where I
love I just I love that I think that's
great
and I think there's a lot of room there
for us to kind of play around in IOT the
other part I really like too is art
whenever I travel the cities I always
try to go to Newark Museum I personally
think that the people in this room you
are we're uniquely positioned to explore
this new area of art I think a lot of
humanities and artists don't know a lot
of programming but I think that like
that's where we're at like there's a lot
there's a lot of exploration that can be
done there I think with the internet
connected art I just love that I love
where we're going with that so IOT so
IOT is anything you put a chip in it and
IOT is exploding and I love art and
stupid [ __ ] with Internet programming
chips in it so great okay that was a
fast version I had to kind of give I had
to trim this up cuz we have 30 minutes
so we've done we're doing the fast
version here today but okay so um I
think this is the part that were that
you'll care about it's uh why should you
be using javascript and IOT went through
next IOT project well first of all did
you know I think actually the node
foundation who runs this conference they
did a study and they found that actually
over 50% 58% of IOT developers
self-identify as no developers it's the
primary language IOT is being developed
in today personally this is an opinion
but I think JavaScript's a great
language for new debt new developers so
if you're new to programming right I
think it's a great choice as opposed to
like C or C++ which are like there are
advantages that memory-wise space-wise
performance wise but low level languages
I think can be difficult you learn I
personally I program in C and C++ and I
prefer JavaScript every time it's just
easier and more fun I'm more comfortable
fit especially if you've never done and
I
tea project like learning the hardware
is already like kind of a step you have
to learn and like learning a new
language is on top that's kind of
challenging to you I just use what you
know you know other thing that why
JavaScript's really popular is it's
super easy to update so you can just
have a command that goes out to all of
your sensors out in the field and tell
to do a git pull an NPM install and boom
you're out you're updated with like C or
C++ traditionally you have to reflash
those chips with the new hardware or
with the new software excuse me that can
be expensive and time-consuming and
challenging to do over a network
remotely and tell the internet really
speaks JavaScript we're already
communicating on the net why can't we
communicate with IOT projects also with
JavaScript there's a ton of libraries
actually it's been around I've been
actually developing an IOT and
JavaScript for years now and there's
it's pretty mature it's a pretty mature
platform the two big ones right now our
Cylon Jas may know that from Battlestar
Galactica or Johnny v from the nineteen
eighty-something movie short circuit
I'll be going over I built my Liberty
but litter box using Johnny v we'll be
going over code samples with that today
okay
and also node in JavaScript it speaks
events it's a venture oven reads
callbacks to kind of handle callbacks of
promises handle events right we have
some sort of event
trigger some callback to handle it
that's basically how I you t-works we're
waiting for something to happen and we
want to do something so for example
maybe I have a moisture sensor and it's
waiting for the like a water event to
happen on that sensor and we want to do
something with that we want to analyze
it and send it off to our centralized
server cool or we have a light sensor
that's waiting for it to get dark we
want to trigger some sort of callback
function happen when that event gets
triggered javascript speaks that
language of physical hardware already
it's it's it works it works just fine
it's that's how we're building it
anyways it's native and if that's
helpful because it helps reduce the cost
of listening it makes it more power
efficient instead of having to do work
all the time we just do work when an
event gets triggered all right so
recap why should you be considering
JavaScript and node for your next IOT
project 58 of 58 percent of IOT
developers already self-identify as no
developers it's super easy for new
developers to learn C and C++ great for
a lot of reasons there are reasons why
you would want to use those for a
project but I would argue javascript is
a great it works in it's great anyway so
super easy to update over network you
have to reflash anything just get pole
npm install'
done and it already speaks JavaScript
super mature platform and javascript is
an adventure of a language which is
natively how physical hardware works
well all right any questions so far
we're doing good on time great okay
I want to make a little note about my
personal philosophy on technical talks
I love having real projects in my at my
talks I think it makes kind of abstract
examples more concrete however there's a
fine line have you guys been the talks
before where the whole thing is just
code and then you lose track and your
eyes kind of glaze over I have that like
all the time
or if I like stop paying attention to
like two seconds and I get toy lost and
then the rustic talk I have no idea
what's going on I'm trying to bet find a
balance there between like making it
like less abstract but not have everyone
plays out so we do do a little bit of
actual code we're not gonna be doing a
deep dive in anything today though we
have 30 minutes again we're gonna kind
of go into it though if you do want to
go into it deeper I will be available
after the talk on Twitter or like I said
all the code will be on my thing I will
be posting all this stuff to my Twitter
as well so great good great it's already
mentioned I'm a I'm a mom good to be
employee so the question always have to
ask is how do we deal with this data I
want to come at this from an angle of
what you should be considering if you're
if you're choosing a database to store
IOT data so first thing you should be
considering is a database needs to
ingest data quickly so imagine I'm
running a
I have a moisture sensor farm out at my
farm right I have a bunch of little
sensors out measuring the moisture of my
crops maybe have a thousands of them and
all thousand those data of those IOT
sensors are transmitting data back to my
centralized database all at the same
time I need a database that's gonna be
able to handle massive concurrent data
which we see a lot with IOT projects
especially as he starts scaling up right
at home hobby project like my IOT kitty
litter box great can handle one just
fine but what happens if I start
monetizing this and manufacturing and
deploying you know millions these out in
the fields like you need a database
that's gonna be able to handle a
constant stream of data just a massive
amount of concurrent data coming in all
the time so definite consideration entry
of it remember we talked about how
JavaScript and IOT speaks that adventure
of the framework or you also want a
database that can handle events and can
be read in or write based on events
coming in from the field flexible schema
is also something I would strongly
consider as well so a super common
example of IOT projects is upgrading or
adding additional sensors so for example
recently we'll be getting a little bit I
added a switch sensor on the door of my
litter box to tell when I was going into
maintenance mode or when I was opening
it to clean it it was super easy for me
to add that additional sensor data to my
my database I didn't have to do anything
had to change any old data accidentally
character like great just like after you
know March 3rd I'm just gonna start
tracking all of my additional new sensor
data not a problem not a problem super
easy so definitely consider I feel like
I owe t projects are more flexible their
schema than other other types of
projects and lastly
time series data so there's lots of
there's lots of ways to save your data
with IOT project but time series data is
probably the best way and that's because
a lot of times when you're if you're
reading or you're saving data to it IOT
database you're probably doing some sort
of reporting on it that's traditionally
what you do you make some start ad in a
dashboard showing the data over time at
some sort of time period and yeah I may
be biased but MongoDB is a
choice for this it does although simile
more I'm gonna be going into a little
bit just briefly how to do how I I
implemented time series data with my
kitty litter box today - right so IOT
data best practices what should you be
considering if you are considering
saving data for IT project you need a
database that handles massive concurrent
read rights you want a database that the
bench ribbon you want a database that
can handle flexible schema oops and you
want a database that can handle time
steers what they do well or natively
right all right easy
so I eighty data best practices awesome
this is my favorite part
IOT kitty litter box so let's jump into
some practical code so I built a IOT
kitty litter box and that's my cat
jumping on the Box to the very end of
that thing but I sprang for a
mid-century modern kitty litter box I'm
aware this is extra you can buy a just
$20 thing on Amazon just a little
clothes covered thing on it no problem
but he worth it so it's a little extra
for it one of them note I want to say
about this to this project is actually
still working progress I have the MVP
done I'm still actively working on this
project if you do want to watch me
continue to work on this project you
could totally check it out I'm streaming
this weekly on the [ __ ] DB twitch
channel find a link to it there and some
videos of me working on actually on our
YouTube channel right now - if you want
to check that out I love this so it's a
great way to like jump in and like I
just love sermons which is the best so
you could check me out on there whoops
this is my cat eating my prototype slash
helping out and I think heed any permit
damage and he didn't get electrocuted
which is great too
right I I have a 3d printer I print out
some stuff 3d printers and not required
for this but I would recommend getting a
Raspberry Pi you can work with a bunch
of other stuff johnny-five works with a
bunch of different IOT
hardware cling Arduinos whatever I use
Raspberry Pi it's super easy great you
can run a full node runtime environment
on there no problem I think it's really
great way to jump in as a beginner the
one downside it's a credit card size but
you can buy much smaller
internet-connected chips these days -
okay so I think it's helpful to talk
about how all we can actually use the PI
and JavaScript to to interact with the
real world and that's through the GPIO
the general purpose input output board
and this is actually how we're doing it
for me and this was the hardest part for
me to grok when I was first starting IOT
projects like okay great I get
programming I get servers I get the
front end but how do I start interacting
with the real world and it's through
these pins so you can see here this is a
little prototype hooked up to a
breadboard
with data flowing in and out of the GPIO
and on the on the PI there you can see
on the top row with those little black
and white wires connected up that's
where the GPIO pins on there I think
there's like 35 of them but the GPIO
there's two types of pins well there's
two types and power pins the first is
output so these are things that your PI
you can like send out to the world to go
do things on it
like turning a switch on and off or an
LED on and off you go out to do things
the other one is input so reading in
sensor data from the outside world for
example sensor data or light sensors or
weight data or whatever you're just
waiting for the data to come in reading
that in I have no idea what all these
pins do their unmarked on the PI and
most and most most ships in general
every time that I have to interact that
I have to Google what they are and I say
that just to make it okay for you to
have to Google stuff I don't I'm still
learning this stuff
I've memorized it I have to Google all
of it all the time I don't know but when
you're in it working with it just google
it people tell you like they do this pin
do whatever or they give you some sort
of schema diagram you can like kind of
copy just plug it in okay cool so let's
jump into the real code here's another
link there too
great let's jump with some real code I
want to start from the I want to kind of
take you through a journey of how I put
this box together from the beginning to
end so the first thing I always do with
an IOT project is actually just getting
that dang led to blank that's the hello
world of IOT projects and you can see
here this is my demo
it basically means I've initialized that
sensor correctly and I'm interacting
with the hardware in the GPIO correctly
right just like with traditional
development we do iterative developments
on this thing I do one little thing test
it out make sure we're good to go and
then I can upgrade up to the next piece
so this is even before I really knew the
schema and what I need to do I just kind
of set up the board I just installed a
note on the board set it all up connect
it up a diagram and then I tried doing
it and this is what the code looks like
for just a hello world for a IOT project
so I'm using johnny-five as we talked
about I mentioned johnny-five
also is compatible with a bunch of
different boards so we need to bring in
the package for raspberry PI's because
that's what working with we initialize
that board until it hey with johnny-five
working with a Raspberry Pi today cool
get that started and then we have a
callback function that is ready so when
that board has been initialized and
saying great you run that up we just
tell it which pin so we're saying on the
GPIO the 13th pin which I had to go to
Wikipedia for to find out which pin that
actually was and then we has a function
just called blank and that's it it's
super nice I'd love johnny-five said
super expressive it's just they have a
bunch of different sensors and it knows
how to work with them so I just have to
invoke the function than one of you but
get the hello flight that's only a
couple lines of code to get that led to
blink and I can move that around I had
to be honest - I had to look up the
circuit diagram for how to hook up an
LED johnny-five had a bunch of stuff on
that - I took one electrical engineering
class in college I don't remember any of
it and I remember any of it
I know this like things with resistors I
have to Google it every time I'm just
like I want to lower the barrier of
entry and say you don't be an expert to
do this stuff you can figure it out okay
great so we got our hello world working
whoo
cool let's make a toilet I have a
variation let's talk where it's a IOT
but Internet of toilets so we're gonna
we're getting we're getting into the IOT
projects okay so how does this work I
want to go high level over how this like
how this works we got over kitty litter
box here too
and what happens is I have a switch on
it so when I take the top off of my box
it goes into maintenance mode
maintenance mode means I'm either
removing clumps from the box or I'm
adding more sand to it point is though
the maintenance mode tells it allows me
to figure out when I need to recalibrate
the base weight of the box so when I put
that that weight or that close that box
up again that switch closes I say great
so either I added or move something but
I need to refigure out with the base
weight of that boxes and then I have to
what I'm doing is waiting for a
cat-sized weight to get added to that
that new initialized base weight after
the maintance motive gets added so I'm
waiting for that cat sighs wait to pop
in I do a so the box I'm keeping track
and passively tracking my cat's weight
so I have weight sensors in the bottom
of the box and when that cat size weight
gets added I measure his weight and I'm
saving that to a database he's doing
some sort of business on there and I
send that data out there I couldn't wait
for I wait 15 seconds so kind of these
scratches and kind of digs a little bit
I wait for kind of chill and then I take
his weight and then once that cat size
weight leaves again I recalibrate the
box weight again and then I wait for a
new events happen either a new
maintenance mode or a new cat sized
thing I have not figured out what would
happen if a raccoon or a possum in the
box or a small dog but it probably I
would assume it's my cat over time so
but the point is I can track things like
my cats bathroom habits and his weight
over time see if I see drastic changes
for that - I haven't done this yet but I
would love to do like some machine
learning models so they predict my cat's
bathroom habits I want to go like just
way too far down this rabbit hole of
Internet toilet data
we'll see what happens I haven't done it
yet okay great so that's how like how
the box is working from a high level
let's dig into actually I'm building the
code up so we're doing the same thing we
did before we're initializing a brand
new johnny-five Raspberry Pi board and
then we wait for that ready event and
then the first thing I'm gonna do then
is set up the maintenance mode and
lalala oh we have a switch so it's a
magnetic switch I have on the door and
just senses when it's open or closed
depending on how close that switches
together and when it's open we have some
sort of event that chap ins and I set
the maintenance mode and once the
maintenance happen I do that
recalibration and whatever I need to do
- so this is a little demo it's a little
hard to see let's see if I can figure
this out they made you to record a new
video but you can see the switch on the
side there and just got cut off there
you can see it the sensors sensing the
open and close events for when that door
gets open to her it's goes into
maintenance mode or not again the switch
doesn't matter you could get most cheap
ones just put it on the side there so
you pop that top off you need something
we need some way to track that whether
it's a minutes long
I thought about other things too like a
physical switch if he kept like an open
box there's a ton of things you can do
for that does really matter but okay so
switch the codes really easy for that's
not too bad the interesting part is the
load cells so I'm using I made my own
internet-connected scale that goes
underneath the box and that's what's
measuring the weight and waiting for cat
sized things to enter the box so here's
the tricky part I couldn't actually find
any support for these load cells that I
purchased with johnny-five so I had to
get a little creative but I still got to
do some cool stuff with node that you
may or may have played with I hadn't but
let me show you so I actually I did find
a library in Python which was able to
interact the load cells this is the code
I want you to it's like doing some stuff
doesn't matter the while loop is where
the interesting stuff happens so it's
just constantly it's a never-ending
while loop that's just getting away from
the box the important part here is that
print statement so I'm actually using
odhh spawn child process to spin up a
Python process and read that data for me
which I had never done before because
the first time I did this I set up my
own Python server and then I had Swift
up WebSockets just real time stream that
data to my node service but was like a
pain in the ass and like I just start
both these services and if one of them
went down the whole thing crashed it was
just a massive pain to maintain and like
frankly overkill child process to me the
super super super easy to run so the
print statement is actually how I'm
sending data up to the child process so
this is the node code for our running
that I'm just requiring and that's that
child spawn child process code and then
I'm Rick the process of bringing it is
that Python code and then detach means
it runs on a separate thread so I've one
I just do MPM start an NPM start and
note is responsible for starting up all
my node services and then it's just
waiting for data so we're saying on data
read it in and the way you send data
from that spawn child process is through
that print statement you just print out
the console and the parent process my
node process reads in anything you're
printing the console so I'm just doing
that for loop every staff a second I'm
just sending that data up to my parent
child or my parent node process and then
it reads it in with that callback
function and then I parse it in comes in
a string and then I breed it and then do
some do some sort of work with it and
then you also have data and error and a
close event to you can also work with
you but isn't it worked at spawn child
process this was like the mysterious
part about node ahead like not worked
with yet I've worked the streams else
other stuff but I'd never didn't spawn
child process so it's actually pretty
jazz I got to play around this a little
bit to you so he came to an IOT talking
maybe learned a little something about
spawning some child processes to you but
it made my project so much more easier
to put together so much easier
troubleshoot
I love it okay so I want to give a quick
demo of how this actually works so you
can see a little bit little piece of
plywood there that's actually my scale
I just bought a piece of plywood the
load sensors are loaded to the bottom of
it I have that little caption there like
kind of messes can't see really anything
but I'm pressing on the board and you
can see that that data being registered
from my node project and you can see the
little magnetic switch also hooked up on
the door over there too but the routing
zeroes press God I really need to record
a new video here you see nothing great
cool so this part was the trickiest part
but I think it's great
I do I do some math and some things on
there it's kind of zeroed out
recalibrate whatever but doesn't matter
what it is I just kind of whatever it
that I just set a base wait and I wait
for some sort of way increase to happen
okay well I do want to talk to about so
I promised I'd show you my time series
data and how I'm actually saving the
state of the database I'm gonna post a
link here on the bottom if anyone wants
200 free credits 200 ollars and free
credits to MongoDB Atlas there's a link
there to off a link at the end and
there's a link on that that page there
too but I'm saving all my data in a
MongoDB database and this is actually
what my time series data looks like for
my kitty litter box so I have some basic
metadata about my box what it is I built
some additional metadata in there too I
don't know in the event I start mass
manufacturing these with my Kickstarter
I don't think I will but like it just to
save some data alright so know who it is
or if I get more cats or whatever I can
potentially save that data and then I
have an array of events and the events
are just denoted by timestamp and a
weight and also I'm tracking things like
maintenance mode that's when that door
gets opened so like for example I'm out
of toner now I have a rover watching my
cat I can track how many times that box
get to open one on the road
so by noting that the maintenance mode
time series data down there too
and it's super easy to add or update
things in there but every time an event
gets triggered I'm just appending a
thing on here one note I will say about
time series data the way I would
recommend constructing it is based on
how you want to do reporting so
sometimes you're getting sensor data
every half a second so I want to get on
record moisture data sensor data from a
field of every seconds from a thousand
sensors that may be a little crazy I'm
doing mine by day cuz I'm doing
reporting like base Sunday how many
times the bathroom is it getting is he
going in a day or how many times get
cleaned a day but maybe
you have massive data you want to do it
by minute so the event is every minute
you're creating a brand new document and
keeping track of their idea or maybe a
year maybe you're only sporadically
keeping track of it right I think with
like a document database like this you
can be far more expressive about how you
are saving the data and the way I'm
doing it is I'm I'm saving the data in
the way I want to read it on my
analytics charts I don't have to I don't
have to do it's already pre computed I
just pull it in read that data boom it
works
I don't have to do any weird math or
anything that I'm save it the way I want
to read it
make me far more expressive okay I want
to talk to just I want to show you like
some of the final pieces there too
let me kind of put in the whole box
together the single power file that goes
in the back can I save them or stop this
let's see you can see the pie I'm just
mounted to a board on the inside there I
3d printed out a case for it and I use
some high-tech duct tape to kind of put
those cards low this safe make sure the
cables are in place which is great you
could see on the bottom a little red
cable that's all the sensor data coming
in from the the load cells okay great
last thing I must show here to uh is
there we go so I'm reporting I did put
it front end together for this and I'm
saving and that so I can dashboard it
check it out I'm still working on doing
additional reporting for it too but I
have basic stuff for it too
there's a link to the site too on the on
that that bitly link I gave you as well
so great so I do have a couple more to
do items I do want to do it I mentioned
this is a work in progress but something
I want to do is hook up stitch bugs to
do like weekly email reports I don't
want to get like a text message or email
every time a cat goes about them I
frankly don't care that much but be nice
to get like some like weekly data or
some ia curcuit data or run some
additional analytics on it I'd also love
to do some more front-end stuff with it
and like I mentioned - I would love to
juice like some machine learning with it
- I just want like I said I just like
data I'm like I want to like I want to
take it to the logical extreme see how
far we're gonna push it so
okay great so we went over a real-world
example I hope that you see that the
code actually isn't that complicated
we're connected to it we tell what pin
that go to and we have some callback
functions we can do some work with on it
it's actually not that bad but we talked
briefly about the GPIO how are you
sending data out and in to the board
we're over a hello world making the LED
blink using johnny-five and over a
Sperry PI we went over the code for how
I did that switch data and how I handle
the load cell data we went over the
spawn child process to handle that
Python subcode we went over the IOT time
series data and how we sent that to the
club and then we went over kind of my
next steps for what I want to do the
project as well okay great let's see
here
alright last part here the future
I love presentations that go over like
their predictions this stuff is all
speculative they're educated guesses but
it's work I I don't know what's next
what's next and what's what are we can
start with two so four thinks I see
first thing duh we're gonna continue
seeing smaller and smaller devices that
are more powerful I'm using the
Raspberry Pi 3 B plus the resume for
just came out super-powerful overkill
for my project didn't need it but we're
gonna continue to see smaller and
smaller chips being added on every day
and I think that trend is just continue
happen we've seen stuff like even chips
you can sew in your clothing
we're seeing great stuff I love when
downside to JavaScript currently is its
footprint so it's garbage collection
it's huge and it takes a it's a minor
memory footprint when you're installing
that out of device I think that we're
gonna see JavaScript footprint getting
smaller and smaller and more optimized
versions for for hardware - it works
fine but that be may one caveat if space
and memory is a major concern for you
you would maybe want to consider using C
or C++ you're handling all the memory on
your own there's like no garbage let
it's like you're responsible
all of it but it also makes it way more
efficient to run on a piece of hardware
we're gonna see better hardware support
- I like him enter the load cells that
wasn't a currently supported by a four
by Johnny Five there's a issue in a PR
open for it right now to get it fixed
and get it natively supported but as the
platform's get more mature and they were
gonna continue to see better hardware
support for that as well and then this
one is always the tricky one and
honestly I think is the biggest issue
for IOT devices today and that's power
and batteries I think we're already
seeing power is already the bottleneck
for our devices today and I feel like
everyone's begging our cellphone
companies to get better battery life and
they're doing it mostly through software
and like just optimizations of the
processes to make better use of the
battery life I feel like I'm happy news
and reddit I see you know graphite
battery breakthrough at MIT labs or
whatever weekly and I don't know I
haven't seen any of that actually come
to consumer market yet but uh I'm
crossing my fingers that that's gonna be
issue regardless though the problem to a
shrinking devices becomes not just
battery life but heat I think a lot of
times right we have those massive
computers that produce a ton of heat as
our devices get smaller and smaller too
and they were gonna produce they're
gonna produce more and more heat - which
also could be a concern as well some
batteries massive problem we have could
crack that yet like my my litter box is
fine I could hook this up to batteries I
have i hook up the wall cuz not moving
much but a lot of wearables have that
but our bottleneck to buy it - okay
great let's do a quick recap and then
we'll wrap it up here so we started the
talk today with just doing a quick
introduction to IOT I tease anything we
put a chip in it we talked about my
favorite types of projects being stupid
ass projects and IOT market is growing
with them with an asterisk there why you
should be considering no JavaScript with
your next IOT project 58% of node
developers already self-identify ot
developers always our self-identify as
no developers javascript is a great
choice for new developers C and C++ are
awesome they're more challenging to
learn them easy to update over a network
that's already
making JavaScript there's a ton of great
existing libraries we went specifically
into johnny-five here today javascript
is already an event-driven language and
then we talked a little bit about IOT
data the best practices so when you're
looking for a UT database or database to
save your IOT data some things you can
should consider are looking at a
database that's able to ingest data
quickly one that is event-driven just
like we talked about javascript of the
callback functions you want one that has
a flexible schema so that you can add
additional sensor data or change that
time series data easily and look for
databases they're able to handle time
series data well to traditional RB meses
can do it well but like we saw with the
document store it's a really easy native
way to do that and it works great for
reporting and analytics then we went
over a real-world example of my IOT
kitty litter box and we first talked
about the GPIO and how to interact with
the real world we talked about that IOT
hello world project making the LED blink
we talked about that switch data and the
load cells you sent some data to the
world or the cloud by and I showed you
that time series data and we talked
about net next ups the project and then
lastly we talked about the future of IOT
with smaller and more powerful devices
and hardware you saw I predict that
JavaScript will continue getting a
smaller and smaller footprint as it gets
more more efficient and will see better
hardware support for the existing
JavaScript and node libraries and lastly
bottle batteries will be continued to
become the bottleneck I'll leave this up
here too I see someone taking photos ok
so next steps - if I've inspired you at
all today
I hope the goal is talk is to give you a
just a gentle introduction to it I also
want to show you that it's ok to not be
an expert at hardware to jump in and
just try stuff out so I hope I've I want
to lower the bar of entry for trying
your own project and if I've inspired
you to do that today awesome and I just
want to talk about what you should do if
you're interested in doing it this is
good this may be lame but I just just
make something make some stupid [ __ ]
make an LED blink make something for you
I get asked all the time - like are you
gonna monetize this or sell it like no I
just made it for me I think it's fine
stupid and I learned something like that
you know and any project even it's a IOT
just go home if you saw something
inspired you this weekend
I saw cool kubernetes talk go home and
just set up a kubernetes project just
for yourself just do it
Google things you get stuck on figure it
out you'll you'll figure it out you'll
everyone this room is intelligent smart
people who can figure out how to do it
too so just make something stupid just
for you
try to figure it out let's see here any
questions up we run run time so I'll be
here for questions of everything but
thank you so much
clap thank you there's the link to the
information and [ __ ] dollars of free
credits and my information here that's
you